The great Adrian Monk.
For a while there, you were
solving a major case every week.
I couldn't have done it alone.
I could have, but it
would have taken longer.
I have traumatic symptoms,
unprecedented in psychiatric history.
He's afraid of heights. It’s his
second biggest fear after germs.
Actually, it goes germs,
needles, birds, then heights.
That was no accident. He was murdered.
You have to help me.
Turn, turn it, turn it, turn it!
There's a bomb!
I know there’s a bomb! You’re not helping!
We should leave a note.
When COVID hit, I was in bad shape.
This is mine.
Look at us.
Everybody's you.
They're gonna hate it.
Here's what happened.
So how does that feel to be working again?
Ah!
Like riding a bicycle.
I'm glad to hear that.
I mean, it's terrifying.